chemielehrer 30
das wirst du die experimente laufen
super doch die letzten wochen kannst du
nichts anderes mehr denken bald die neue
englischlehrerin an deiner wie
wunderschön witzig klug selbstbewusst
und gingen kurz du bist unsterblich
verliebt leider aber ignoriert ich seine
angebetete in einer schlaflosen nacht
und er plötzlich einige durch sollte
doch eigentlich eine liebe dinge
herzustellen die ein feuer der liebe
einfach davon
dieser hätte ich nur noch augen für die
nächsten wochen verbringst du nacht für
nacht im labor bist du endlich die liebe
formel gefunden hat
[Musik]
am nächsten tag beim café sitzt ihr euch
zufällig gegenüber ergibt sich der
perfekte moment und liefert die pilger
unterzuschieben
du weißt er beide wert glücklich bis an
ihr lebensende
was tust du steckst du ihr die
liebesspiele enttäuschen
na klar auf jeden fall auch mit einem
neuen haarschnitt oder einem sinnlichen
parfüm versucht das gefüge zu
beeinflussen liebeskiller ist nur ein
anderes mittel um lieder gedichte
bringen
oder hast du was ich lieber ganz frei
für dich entscheiden soll
aber hast du dich frei für liefer
entschieden
diebe erwischt einen fisch keine freie
entscheidung und schließlich liefering
sich genau wie du nach intensivem imbiss
gefühlen wie würde die pille vermutlich
auch freiwillig nehmen
also was tust du
[Musik]